Je m’en souviens
comme si c’était hier.
À seulement quatre semaines
du concours,
j’ai reçu un message sur Facebook
d’un élève que je suivais
depuis le début de l’année :
« Romain,
je suis super content :
j’ai réussi à mettre la main
sur le cours de Louis Le Grand !
Plusieurs centaines de pages
pleines de références originales ! »
...
Vous avez souvent ce problème :
vous ne savez pas
comment gérer toutes les références
que VOUS CROYEZ
devoir connaître
pour vos épreuves de dissertation.
MAIS vous devez prendre conscience
d’une chose :
vous n’avez PAS BESOIN
de beaucoup de références
pour réussir vos dissertation.
Au contraire,
c’est même dangereux,
L’EXCÈS
de références,
parce que vous n’arriverez pas
à les apprendre
— et même si vous y arrivez,
vous aurez du mal
à les mobiliser en dissertation.
Donc LA MEILLEURE
stratégie,
c’est de maîtriser une quantité
LIMITÉE
de références ESSENTIELLES.
Comme ça,
vous les apprendrez
RAPIDEMENT,
vous les maîtriserez
FACILEMENT,
et vous serez à l’aise
pour les mobiliser en dissertation.
MAIS SURTOUT,
ça vous laissera le temps de travailler
CE QUI EST CRUCIAL
pour réussir une dissertation :
la MÉTHODOLOGIE.
Et là non plus,
vous n’avez pas besoin
de vous prendre la tête :
inscrivez-vous à mon cours gratuit
de méthodologie de la dissertation,
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui apparaît maintenant
en haut à droite de la vidéo,
soit en cliquant sur celui
qui est dans la description
de cette vidéo.
C’est un cours par e-mail,
donc vous pourrez le découvrir
après cette vidéo,
ou bien dans les prochains jours.
Là tout de suite,
restez avec moi,
parce que ce
que je vais vous dire
va vous faire gagner
BEAUCOUP DE TEMPS.
Je vais vous expliquer
comment créer
FACILEMENT
un stock de références
PRÊTES À L’EMPLOI
pour la dissertation,
et comment les apprendre
sans risquer le mal de crâne.
Pour préparer
et apprendre EFFICACEMENT
vos références
en vue de la dissertation,
je vous recommande
TRÈS FORTEMENT
la méthode
« DU FICHIER UNIQUE ».
En quoi consiste cette méthode ?
La réponse est dans le nom :
il s’agit de regrouper
TOUTE L’INFORMATION,
et je dis bien
ABSOLUMENT TOUT,
dans UN SEUL
ET UNIQUE
fichier.
Cette manière de faire
a deux avantages :
d’abord,
elle empêche la dispersion
— vous n’aurez pas
CENT CINQUANTE FICHES
dans VINGT-CINQ
dossiers différents ;
et le second avantage,
c’est que vous pourrez évaluer
FACILEMENT
la quantité d’information que représente
votre stock de connaissances.
Je vous rappelle
que vous devez
VOUS MÉFIER
de l’excès d’information.
En pratique,
pour créer votre fichier unique,
je vous conseille d’utiliser
GOOGLE DOCS,
parce que c’est un éditeur de texte
SIMPLE,
fiable,
et que vous pouvez l’utiliser
PARTOUT,
sur n’importe quel support,
tant que vous avez internet.
Et si vous voulez pousser plus loin
la méthode du fichier unique,
vous pouvez aller jusqu’à stocker
TOUT
le contenu qui concerne
la préparation de votre épreuve de dissertation
dans UN SEUL
fichier.
Dans ce cas,
l’idéal,
à mes yeux,
c’est de stocker les références
dans la première partie du fichier,
ensuite les plans détaillés,
et enfin les dissertations
entièrement rédigées.
Mais bon,
vous n’êtes pas obligés
d’être aussi radicaux.
En revanche,
vous devez À TOUT PRIX
STRUCTURER
votre stock de références.
Si vous vous contentez
de noter les références
dans un fichier unique,
ça risque d’être anarchique.
En particulier,
vous ne saurez pas
si votre stock de références
couvre tout le programme.
Vous avez donc intérêt
À STRUCTURER